you know a hundred people can be in a
room in 99 don't believe in you and just
one person believes in you and it can
change everything
Lady Gaga basking in the big-screen glow
at this week's LA premiere of a star's
born and she just got the endorsement of
another music icon cher no big deal she
just recently praised Gaga's performance
on Twitter quote babe I always felt you
could do it and I'm so proud of you
so great for her and we all know that if
cher doesn't like something or someone
whose name starts with an M she isn't
afraid to share it first of all you
can't tell me not to do something that's
not too stubborn yeah you do not want to
mess with cher at 72 she is still
unfiltered and she just threw shade at
Madonna name three celebrities you'd
want to do a duet with Oh Adele pink and
not Madonna the feud goes back decades
cher said this in 1991 there's something
about her that I don't like she's mean
you know I remember having her over in
my house a couple of times because Sean
and I were friends and she just was
so rude to everybody and she told ET
this eight years later Madonna Madonna
Madonna wears a lot of makeup not like
me she's not a natural beauty like me so
what stars do get shares approval well
she definitely loves ABBA after filming
Mamma Mia here we go again she recorded
an album of covers out today calling it
dancing queen I never did us out but
where I knew all the songs were hits I
mean it was like such a weird thing
going oh my god I remember when that was
a hit and that wasn't it what's next
well cher returns to her Vegas residency
October 31st but we wanted to know about
a return to TV you were one of the best
guest stars and Willie grace I do better
share than you you think so
actually it's you think so ho any chance
we'll see you back on it yeah why not
because I had I would did it two times
and I had a blast I would do it do you
hear that everyone I think that's the
sound of the Will & Grace writers
already writing shares the return and
meanwhile chairs not waiting around
because one she share and two she just
kicked off her first Australian tour in
more than a decade
[Music]
[Applause]